bonjour Christian Campbon bonjour merci
d'être avec nous sénateurs les
républicains du Val-de-Marne vous êtes
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées du Sénat on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes mon interview en partenariat
avec la presse régionale représentée par
Jefferson des sports du Sud-Ouest
aujourd'hui faire ça bonjour Oriane
bonjour Christian bonjour on va
évidemment parler avec vous de la
situation
Ukraine de la loi de programmation
militaire qui est au Sénat mais d'abord
l'actualité Christian Cambon ce sont ces
images encore cette nuit et ses tensions
dans plusieurs villes de France la nuit
précédente c'était cantonnée à Nanterre
et la région parisienne dont le
Val-de-Marne d'ailleurs cette nuit ça
s'est étendue dans tout le pays est-ce
que vous craignez un embrasement
bien sûr je crée un embrassement d'abord
faut dire que c'est un événement
absolument dramatique la mort d'un jeune
de 17 ans quel que soit son pedigree
judiciaire c'est quelque chose
d'épouvantable et rien ne justifie bien
évidemment une affaire de ce genre je
pense que la responsabilité des
politiques c'est d'abord de laisser la
justice suivre son cours beaucoup de
commentaires dans tous les sens et
notamment de ceux qui semblent relancer
la violence la violence ne mène nulle
part donc je pense la violence
il y a une extrême une partie de
l'échiquier à l'extrême gauche qui
prononce des phrases pour lesquelles je
pense qu'il ferait mieux de faire
attention à ce qu'ils disent parce que
toutes ces émeutes ont une nouvelle fois
entrer le pays dans dans une crise dans
des difficultés ça ne ça ne sert pas ça
ne sert pas la cause qu'ils veulent
défendre je crois qu'effectivement
il y a un événement absolument tragique
et une vidéo qui est évidemment tout à
fait choquante
sur la loi de programmation militaire
depuis 48 heures je l'ai vu cette nuit
et à 2h30 quand je suis rentré à mon
domicile et
oui ce que l'on voit est choquant un
discutablement maintenant moi je ne suis
pas ni la justice ni inspection générale
quand vous avez perçu les propos
d'Emmanuel Macron il parle d'un drame
inexcusable inexplicable est-ce que ce
commentaire était approprié
je suis pas certain que ce soit les bons
mots qui calme le jeu la preuve c'est
que cette nuit nous venons de connaître
de très nombreux affrontements dans
différentes villes de France le rôle du
président de la République du Premier
ministre un rôle d'apaisement tout en
laissant bien évidemment la justice
faire son travail et c'est pour ça que
je me refuse à faire des commentaires
il y a la présomption d'innocence et
puis il y a un drame effroyable car
rien n'explique la perte d'un jeune de
17 ans je veux dire c'est
choquant et inexplicable
sur l'usage des armes pour les écouter
il y a une loi déjà en 2017 dont on a
dit qu'elle crève une part de flou par
rapport
au concept de légitime défense avant il
y avait des règles qui étaient assez
simples bon je pense que
la commission des lois au Sénat se
saisir à certainement de ce sujet
je crois que
à ce niveau il faut garder raison
laisser la justice on a une justice qui
est très sévère vis-à-vis la police faut
pas croire que la justice laisse passer
tous ses faits il suffit de regarder les
statistiques on s'y a eu un comportement
terrible de la part de ce policier il y
aura les sanctions qui suivront et je
crois qu'il faut en rester là en tout
cas il y a un chiffre qu'on peut retenir
c'est 25000 refus d'obtempérer par an
est-ce qu'il y a un problème sur ce
terrain il y a un discutablement nous le
voyons nous en banlieue parisienne il y
a un discutablement aussi un
comportement qui se multiplie c'est à
dire que maintenant les injonctions de
la police nationale ou de la gendarmerie
ne sont plus suivis des faits par un une
partie de de gens souvent des jeunes
malheureusement qui considèrent que
l'autorité de l'État n'existe plus
vraiment dans ce pays on va parler de ce
qui s'est passé en Russie et de la
guerre en Ukraine et ce qui s'est passé
il y a quelques jours cette rébellion de
prix gaugine le chef de Wagner rébellion
finalement très vite avorté avec le
recul les six jours de recul comment
vous analysez ce qui s'est passé ce
week-end en Russie le constat que tout
le monde fait ou là et là aussi les
informations sont qui nous proviennent
décrivent des événements différents la
première constatation que l'on peut
faire c'est que Poutine sort très
affaibli de cette histoire car le son
pays tout entier et le monde entier a vu
un chef d'État contesté par quelqu'un
qui paraît-il était là pour le conforter
et qui s'est rebeller contre lui le fait
d'organiser une marche contre une marche
sur Moscou
ça doit être quelque chose qui pour
Vladimir Poutine et absolument de
l'ordre de l'insupportable donc c'est un
affaiblissement de ce régime qui aura
certainement des conséquences quand ou
sous quelle forme personne ne peut le
dire mais manifestement il y a
maintenant un débat qui s'ouvre de
manière assez tragique lui aussi en
Russie je rappelle que Prigogine a dit
publiquement que
les raisons qui avaient lancé Vladimir
Poutine contre l'Ukraine était de
mauvaises raisons c'est à dire que les
promouvoir un groupe de [__]
là aussi
rester très attentif à ce qui se passe
ne pas attendre à mon sens de véritable
bouleversement dans les médias parce que
d'abord on peut
Poutine un peu quitter le pouvoir on ne
sait pas qui peut le remplacer ça peut
être aussi pire il faut pas
négliger ce point mais il faut pas se
réjouir
faut surtout être vigilant faire ce que
nous sommes en train de faire
actuellement ces remuscler nos forces de
de sécurité et nos armées et être
attentif à ce
à cette situation qui partout se dégrade
vous conviendrait quand même que l'on
vit dans un monde depuis quelques temps
qui a perdu ses repères et qui offre
plus d'inquiétudes que de motifs
d'apaisement on a vu aussi la question
qui se pose c'est l'avenir de Wagner
Christian Cambron ces hommes là doivent
peut-être intégrés dans l'armée russe
certains vont partir est-ce que ça peut
affaiblir le front ukrainien côté russe
alors les incertitudes autour de Wagner
le sort de Wagner est évidemment très
important il l'est bien sûr sur le front
sur le front ukrainien puisque les
quelques victoires à Bac mousse étaient
dans quelques autres villages qui
avaient été enregistré ce sont des
victoires de Wagner et non pas des
victoires de l'armée russe est-ce que ça
veut dire que l'armée russe ne peut pas
l'emporter sans Wagner ça c'est la
question qui se pose en tous les cas
pour l'instant Wagner a manifesté par
des actes de violence inouïe enfin ce
sont quand même
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas une armée ce
sont
les gens qui utilisent des méthodes de
contraintes effroyables torture etc et
bien évidemment il joue ils ont joué un
rôle décisif en Ukraine mais ce qui
m'interroge le plus c'est ce qui peut se
passer en Afrique où on sait que un
certain nombre de régimes on fait
confiance à Wagner le Mali notamment le
Mali notamment et donc si jamais Wagner
devait être dissous disparaitre
de ces régimes c'est un vrai sujet aussi
d'inquiétude pour tout le monde parce
que personne n'a intérêt à une
déstabilisation du continent africains
françaises ont été affaiblies
je tombe sur Wagner Christian Cambon on
a vu Poutine a toujours dit que c'était
une société privée qui était loin de son
pouvoir absolu et finalement avec la
rébellion de Prigogine on a vu le lien
et toute cette relation qui n'a aucune
ambiguïté entre le Kremlin et Wagner
est-ce que là c'est le masque qui tombe
sur Wagner et le Kremlin à mon sens il
était tombé depuis longtemps et les
affirmations de Poutine ne trompaient
personne tout le monde savait très bien
que cette cette armée sensing distinctif
sans drapeau
était manipulé depuis Mo cou et donc ça
ça faisait pas l'ombre d'un doute pour
personne donc maintenant c'est une vraie
déstabilisée enfin une tentative de
déstabilisation à l'intérieur à
l'intérieur même de la Russie et donc il
faut être attentif ne pas profiter de
ces événements car encore une fois on ne
sait pas ce qu'ils peuvent venir après
mais ça montre que tout est possible du
jour au lendemain tout est possible
est-ce que les forces ukrainiennes la
contre-offensive ukrainienne va profiter
ou profite de cette rébellion avortée
les renseignements que nous avons sont
parcellaires ont objectivement
aujourd'hui on ne le sait pas ça ça peut
effectivement profiter à la
contre-offensive ukrainienne mais je
pense que la contre-offensive
ukrainienne est organisée depuis
longtemps selon des plans qui sont du
reste assez cohérents alors bien
évidemment si si le pouvoir s'affaiblit
à Moscou ça peut profiter à l'Ukraine
mais on peut aussi avoir une phase de
durcissement c'est à dire que
généralement regardez ce qui s'est passé
dans d'autres pays ce qui s'est passé en
Turquie après le coup d'État il y a eu
quand même un
durcissement de la politique
de Monsieur hardwan et donc on peut
assister à un même phénomène peut-être
plus de répression moins de moins de
liberté pour autant qu'il en reste
encore sur la contre-offensive
ukrainienne vous comme on vous le disiez
parce qu'on parle surtout de coup de
sonde de reconnaissance offensive
finalement le deuxième échelon n'est pas
rentré encore visiblement l'Ukraine
garde des brigades en réserve pour
peut-être un mouvement de plus grande
ampleur est-ce que c'est votre lecture
on n'est pas encore rentré dans la
dernière séquence en tout cas dans la
séquence la plus offensive je le pense
d'autant que c'est un pays qui
véritablement vit lui en est en économie
de guerre c'est-à-dire que tout un pays
y compris sa diaspora y compris des
Ukrainiens qui sont dans d'autres pays
et qui parlent biais de l'informatique
et de toutes les technologies nouvelles
aide leur pays à résister et
déjà l'Ukraine a la première armée
d'Europe en importance ce qui est un
fait évidemment tout à fait nouveau et
donc je crois que
l'offensive n'est pas terminé et il y a
surtout la volonté d'un peuple de
résister et je pense que c'est ça le
sentiment qui prédomine si un peuple ne
veut pas être
occupé et veut résister à un envahisseur
et qu'il est persuadé que sa cause est
juste ça donne ça donne une dynamique ça
donne une force qui est sur mon table je
pense
qu'il le weekend dernier du coup à
pointer la faiblesse totale de la Russie
et il a redemandé des avions est-ce
qu'il faut lui donner
alors bien sûr il y a la nécessité de
maîtriser le ciel en tous les cas il y a
un problème technique qui se pose parce
que si vous voulez donner des avions
c'est donner toute une logistique qui
concourt à faire fonctionner les avions
faut former des pilotes il faut avoir
des gens qui les entretiennent les
avions qui peuvent être donnés puisque
il y a des informations des pilotes là
il y a une formation des pilotes oui qui
est encore qui est actuellement en cours
je crois que c'est dans le sud-ouest de
la France
mais premièrement il faut être très
clair il n'y aura pas de militaires
français qui accompagnons ou qui
viendront si jamais il y avait la
livraison d'avions deuxièmement il faut
que les que cette formation soit solide
parce que on ne sert pas un avion
comment on utilise un fusil ou une
mitraillette donc c'est assez c'est
assez c'est un problème assez compliqué
alors il y a plus compliqué que de
livrer des chats en livrer des avions
parce que c'est toujours l'écosystème
qui va derrière vous il y a une
logistique une maintenance des systèmes
d'armes tout à fait c'est pas un avion
tout seul qui doit arriver d'une part et
puis il faut que le nombre d'avions soit
substantiel parce que et qui soit équipé
qui soit armé bon
en France ce sont des décisions qui
doivent être prises par le Président de
la République j'espère que le Parlement
sera bien évidemment informé de cette
situation pour l'instant doute pour
l'instant on s'interroge encore vous
savez c'est très difficile de rassembler
tous les renseignements qui nous
permettent de nous faire une idée
précise bon il y a des pays qui ont les
pays des Balkans qui ont donné des
notamment des Migs
que l'armée ukrainienne connaissait bien
l'armée-canédienne elle connaît pas de
mal les mirages qui seraient
susceptibles le cas échéant de céder des
F-16 qui que le crâne demande nous
avions américains tout à fait et on va
parler de la loi de programmation
militaire ça fait ça fait lien entre les
deux cette loi de programmation
militaire qui vise à redonner évidemment
des moyens à notre armée est-ce que la
guerre en Ukraine et ce qu'on a donné à
l'Ukraine ça affaiblit notre armée
est-ce qu'elle est affaiblie aujourd'hui
suffisamment forte même si cela pose un
certain nombre de problèmes elle peut
être affaiblie au sens où nous avons
déjà livré un certain nombre de matériel
de munitions des chars MX10 qui servent
sont déjà anciens mais qui fonctionne en
cas de conflit de très haute intensité
on serait bien content de de les avoir
mais nous souhaitons aider l'Ukraine
comme le font l'immense majorité des
pays occidentaux donc je crois que bien
évidemment il faut tenir compte et la
loi de programmation militaire le fait
tenir compte de ce fait nouveau et de
faire en sorte que on puisse renouveler
nos stocks notamment de munitions car
comme vous le savez au sein des armées
françaises nous nous sommes compétents
sur tous les segments mais il nous
manque parfois l'épaisseur je prends un
exemple en fin de enfin 2025 sous le
régime de la loi de programmation
militaire actuelle nous aurons en stock
en missile en missile complexe l'é qui a
été tiré la semaine dernière en Ukraine
il faut monter cet effort là en tout cas
dans la loi de programmation militaire
il y a les défauts de la défense
antillaisienne qui est ciblée le
renseignement beaucoup de crédits dans
ces domaines-là est-ce que ça va dans la
bonne direction Christian Cambon avant
de rentrer dans le détail financier qui
est l'objet de votre commission en tout
cas de la discussion au Sénat oui
indiscutablement le fait
d'avoir consenti un effort de cette
importance je rappelle que la loi de
programmation militaire qui est censé se
terminer en 2025 c'est 295 milliards 190
milliards on passe à 413 milliards donc
déjà c'est un effort de plus de 100
milliards qui est considérable le
problème c'est que cet effort
considérable n'est pas aussi apparent
que on pourrait le penser pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce qu'il va y avoir
un effet d'inflation nous en avons
longuement discuté cette nuit
on prévoit que 30 milliards de ces
crédits seront mangés si j'ose dire
érodé par l'inflation donc évidemment ça
diminue l'enveloppe d'investissement
j'allais dire mécaniquement
deuxièmement il faut bien comprendre une
autre chose c'est que nous étions sur
des matériels un peu plus anciens
certains dataient même général de Gaulle
enfin je veux dire les Alouettes que
l'on va enlever les les Pumas tout ça
c'est du matériel du temps de la guerre
froide bon on va les changer
les matériels nouveaux incorporent
beaucoup d'innovations le programme
scorpion ce sont des engins blindés
connectés extrêmement protecteur pour
les soldats qui les sert donc ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher un Rafale coûte
beaucoup plus cher qu'un mirage donc il
y a aussi cette dimension là c'est à
dire que au final vous ne pouvez pas
avoir autant de matériel que vous en
aviez précédemment mais vous avez du
matériel qui sur le plan de l'équipement
est beaucoup plus performant donc il
faut tenir compte de toutes ces données
mais juste qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
est-ce qu'il faut se doter d'un maximum
d'équipements ou est-ce qu'il faut
fléchir les investissements vers les
équipements qu'on a déjà pour qu'il soit
utilisable c'est aussi une des questions
Sébastien lecornuy dit faut privilégier
la cohérence sur la masse mais nous
sommes tout à fait de cet avis nous
sommes tout à fait de cet avis car nous
pensons qu'effectivement rien ne sert
d'entasser dans des hangars des chats
dont on ne peut pas se servir
actuellement on a quatre régiments de
Charles clair mais du fait d'une mise en
condition opérationnelle qui n'est pas
au de ce qu'elle doit être
ces régiments fonctionnent à 50% de leur
capacités c'est à dire que les durées
d'entraînement sont inférieures à ce
qu'elles pourraient être les munitions
manquent parfois ou en tous les cas les
militaires n'ont pas l'autorisation de
les utiliser parce que les stocks sont
insuffisants donc si vous voulez je
pense que la manière dont le ministre
voit l'utilisation de ces crédits est
évidemment importante puisque la mise en
condition opérationnelle et fondamental
si vous voulez si vous avez des chars il
faut aussi que dans le même temps le
génie par exemple puisse avoir ses
engins qui permettront un char de
franchir une rivière il faut que notre
service de santé des armées pour lequel
il manque actuellement plus de 100
médecins il faut reconstituer toutes ses
forces parce que si on sera au
rendez-vous Christian comment faisons
tout nous faisons tout pour qu'elle le
soit c'est compliqué c'est difficile
parce que c'est une somme importante
mais s'il fallait remonter les 25 ans
des ratements des armées que tous les
régimes de droite et de gauche ont
organisé parce que c'était plus facile
de reprendre des crédits aux forces
armées qui généralement ne respectent
pas et donc on équilibré en quelque
sorte de budget comme ça et puis c'était
un temps de paix on vivait depuis 75 ans
un temps de paix donc c'était assez
difficile pour un ministre du Budget de
quelques sensibilités que ce soit de
dire tiens j'ai une bonne idée je vais
acheter 800 millions de munitions de
façon dans 5 ans elles sont périmées on
continuera comme ça non c'est pas
possible donc il faut faut mesurer un
tout petit peu son jugement par rapport
à la situation d'avant et il est un fait
que l'invasion de l'Ukraine a
complètement changé nos logiciels
puisque maintenant c'est un pays qui
était un pays ami qui était un pays avec
lequel nous travaillons ensemble membre
du Conseil de sécurité signataire de la
Charte des Nations Unies ce pays se
permet d'attaquer son voisin souverain
c'est-à-dire qu'on revient à des
concepts qui étaient ceux de la dernière
guerre si vous le voulez en tout cas il
y a une vraie discussion si financière
entre le gouvernement et le Sénat
Christian condom expliquez-nous parce
que vous avez décidé à vous proposer au
gouvernement de dépenser plus au début
de la LPM et un peu moins après alors
que c'était l'inverse qui prévalait donc
vous changez finalement le cadencement
de financement qui était programmé c'est
une vraie discussion et un point
d'achoppement avec le gouvernement on en
est où ce matin est-ce que la discussion
est réglée ce point-là vous avez trouvé
un accord ou c'est dans les prochaines
heures alors
nous avons dit la séance est terminée
vers 1h du matin on est resté encore
près d'une heure avec
mon équipe et la sienne jusqu'à plus de
deux heures pour essayer de rapprocher
les points de vue je pense qu'il y a
deux sujets le premier sujet c'est le
cadencement la loi a été présentée sur
la base d'un niveau de dépense de
l'ordre de 3 milliards
par an chaque année
c'est exactement ce que prévoyait
l'ancienne LPM donc un certain nombre de
sénateurs et à l'Assemblée c'était
pareil on dit mais à quoi ça sert de
présenter une nouvelle LPM si c'est pour
dépenser la même chose donc nous ce que
nous avons dit c'est qu'il faut modifier
le cadencement et dépenser plus vite
pourquoi d'abord je l'ai dit à cause de
l'inflation plus on attend et plus on
paye plus tard un euro d'aujourd'hui euh
ne vaudra plus qu'un euro en 2030 si
l'inflation demeure deuxièmement nous
sommes on vient de le décrire nous
sommes dans un état de très grande
tension la France n'est pas un état de
guerre mais maintenant la guerre elle
est à 3h de Paris donc un conflit peut
dégénérer personne ne peut dire ce qui
va se passer dans 3 mois dans 6 mois ou
dans un an donc ce que nous disons c'est
que c'est maintenant qu'il faut dépenser
de l'argent et non pas après les
élections présidentielles or dans le
cadencement qui avait été présenté par
le gouvernement ont renvoyait au futur
président de la République le soin de
franchir des marches plus hautes donc là
je pense que ce message lui a été bien
compris rien ce problème qui se pose et
qui nous a animé une bonne partie de la
nuit et qui va nous réunir tout à
l'heure pour essayer de trouver les
voies de passage c'est qu'effectivement
le Parlement a aussi son avis sur la
manière dont on utilise cet argent et on
n'a pas mis des marges on n'a pas
augmenté les marges pour le plaisir de
dire on va mettre plus d'argent moi
j'avais donné comme orientation à mes
rapporteurs de dire si vous voulez plus
d'argent dites à quoi il doit servir
des crédits réfléchi des crédits pour
aujourd'hui vous êtes plus vous à 416
420 qu'à 413 milliards nous sommes c'est
un une vraie discussion qui est trop
compliquée pour que on puisse en finir
là dans cet instant nous nous sommes sur
413 milliards que les choses soient
claires les procès d'intention qui ont
été faits donc ils font partie de la
polémique habituelle dans ce genre de
débat non pas lieu d'être nous sommes
c'était rappelé par Bruno retaillod
c'était rappelé du reste par tous les
groupes nous sommes à 413 milliards et
nous voulons tenir dans cette enveloppe
mais le Parlement a le droit de dire
comment il faut utiliser cet argent et
pour l'instant vous aurez voulu fléchir
ces crédit dont vous nous parlez alors
on l'a mis prioritairement j'essayais
d'être logique avec moi-même si j'ose
dire on le met sur l'entraînement
puisque je viens j'ai expliqué que nous
manquons d'entraînement je viens de
l'expliquer pour les régiments de chat
sur les pilotes de Rafale les pilotes de
Rafale sont actuellement à peine pour
une grande partie d'entre eux à 145
heures d'entraînement la norme autant
c'est 220 heures donc
si vous ne pouvez pas faire voler un
pilote il perd une partie de son
savoir-faire et puis il risque aussi de
quitter les forces armées et d'aller se
faire engager chez Air France aux
Transavia pour pour piloter plus
régulièrement je caricature mais enfin
vous voyez il y a ce problème là de
fidélisation des armées auquel cas il
faut les faire travailler il faut bien
évidemment leur donner les moyens de
s'entraîner et vous défendez aussi un
livret d'épargne souveraineté
le livret d'épargne souveraineté c'est
pour répondre à un cri un cri d'alarme
et un cri de toutes les petites et
moyennes entreprises de la défense vous
savez le secteur des industries de la
défense ce sont 200 000 salariés en
France pour une bonne part ce sont des
petits et moyennes entreprises qui sont
sur des niches excessivement innovantes
mais qui malheureusement du fait d'un
état d'esprit général d'une
réglementation imposée par Bruxelles ce
que l'on appelle sous le sous ce joli
nom de taxonomie et il dit alors les
bosser dire non non non c'est pas bien
c'est pas bien de financer les
industries de défense et donc ces petits
et moyennes entreprises risque soit
d'être achetés ce qui est une perte de
souveraineté pour nous soit depuis
bagages et de perdre cette ce ses
capacités d'innovation et donc nous nous
disons pourquoi les Français ne
pourraient pas s'intéresser à leur
propre sécurité en ouvrant un livret
souveraineté comme on peut s'intéresser
au développement durable et ouvrir au
financement de ces entreprises c'est pas
à nous moi je ne suis pas la commission
des finances et je suis encore moins le
ministère de Bercy c'est pas à nous
d'organiser ce que pourrait être ce
livret de souveraineté mais c'est un
appel très fort pour que la France
prenne conscience du fait que le
financement de sa propre sécurité ça
peut concerner n'importe qui et
quelqu'un peut vouloir un citoyen normal
peut vouloir mettre sans de 100 500
euros sur un livret plus s'il le
souhaite ou s'il le peut c'est tout à
fait volontaire pour justement
participer au financement de ce de
l'industrie de défense avec en touchant
les intérêts d'un livret alors on nous
dit qu'on veut lit vider le livret A je
pense que tout ça est absolument
mesuré par rapport
à une question très rapide comme on
parle de finance et de cette LPM est-ce
que vous avez reçu un coup de fil ou
d'Élisabeth borne Bruno Le Maire sur ce
cadencement de du financement de la LPM
parce qu'on sait qu'on est dans une
période très contrainte on est à l'euro
près explique Bruno Le Maire alors
est-ce que c'est perçu du côté de Bercy
ou de Matignon pour proposition j'ai une
demande de contact de du cabinet de
Bruno Le Maire j'ai eu la première
ministre mais la tradition fait qu'on ne
révèle pas les contenus des
conversations mais je pense que nous
reverrons d'ici là
c'est bien perçu ou pas je suis
naturellement optimiste et je veux je
souhaite que nous aboutissions et que
nous puissions doter nos forces armées
d'une loi de programmation militaire on
va y arriver il y a encore un peu de
boulot mais on va y arriver bon allez au
Sénat
amen normalement vous finissez l'examen
on va finir ce soir merci Christian
Cambon merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité à l'une de sud-est c'est la mort
de Naël brûlante colère c'est à la Une
de votre journal Jefferson merci
Jefferson et on va reparler de ce sujet
et de ses tensions dans plusieurs villes
du pays tout de suite dans le cadre des
territoires